This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Audible.
Feeling uncreative?
Just take a walk!
But first, watch this video.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - with yet another
reason to get up off your butt and move.
If you're like me, you probably spend several
hours a day in front of a computer - and every
so often, you need a jolt of creative inspiration.
Well, a new study from Stanford University
shows that walking - might be the best way
to go about that.
The study looked at 176 college students,
who were engaged in some kind of creative
exercise, while either sitting or walking.
They divided them into 4 groups, so half were
inside - either sitting, or walking on a treadmill
- and the other half were outside, either
walking or being pushed on a wheelchair to
simulate the visual sensation of walking.
They found that regardless of whether the
person was inside or outside - the simple
act of walking, significantly boosted their
creativity.
And that creativity continued, even after
the person sat down.
Perhaps more surprising, is that the people
inside walking on the treadmill, were facing
a completely blank wall, with no stimulation
whatsoever.
And they STILL produced twice as many creative
responses than people who were sitting, outside
or inside.
So walking induces creativity.
That is the take-home message of this study.
But what effect does it have on other kinds
of thought processes?
Well, to test that - they repeated the same
experiments, but instead of a creative exercise,
they had people do word association tasks,
which have a single correct answer, and require
much more focused levels of thinking.
Surprisingly, the people who were walking
- actually performed worse on those exercises,
than the people who were sitting.
So if you need a creative boost - take a walk.
But if you're looking for the answer to a
specific problem - sitting might be the way
to go.
If you're looking for even more ways to improve
your mind, remember you can read AND walk
at the same time - with Audible!
Audible.com is the leading provider of downloadable
digital audiobooks and spoken word entertainment,
with over 100,000 titles to choose from in
every genre you can imagine.
Just download a book to your iPod/MP3 player,
and play it back anywhere, anytime.
Sign up today at audiblepodcast.com/dnews
and we will hook you up with a FREE Audiobook
download of your choice.
I recommend "Surely You're Joking, Mr. Feynman"
- a hilarious and entertaining autobiography
of one of the leading pioneers of quantum
physics.
Again, the link is Audiblepodcast.com/dnews
for your Free Audiobook download!
Meanwhile if you guys have any suggestions
on ways to boost creativity - let us know
in the comments below - and as always, you
can watch more episodes of Dnews by subscribing
here.